pratiquement plus de médias
saint-honoré-les-bains semble avoir
retrouvé son calme aux abords de la
désormais ex maison occupée
cet homme nous fait entrer dans les
lieux c'est le fils de la propriétaire
il est de toute évidence soulagement je
suis nouveau chez moi je suis rassurée
pas totalement toujours un doute à
l'esprit que
hiro viennent ces décès des personnes
qui ont leur une autre façon de penser
donc si en face ont un peu simple ils
sont dans leur monde
alors moi une assurance et un aplomb
déroutant fin juillet ce couple rentre
dans cette maison inoccupée sans droit
ni titre alors que sa propriétaire est
en ehpad
ils iront même jusqu'à tirer une ligne
électrique depuis un local communal
voisins cette affaire rappelle celle
survenue à théoule sur mer mais ici la
préfecture a pu lancer une procédure de
mise en demeure ce qui a débloqué la
situation
spike lee qui reviennent donc au moins
aujourd'hui je vois pour moi c'est chez
moi
et puis on va la vie reprend son cours
je vais rassurer ma mère m'a montré que
les choses continuent on est chez nous
comme d'habitude
interpellé hier par la gendarmerie alors
qu'il circulait dans les rues du village
le couple de squatters a été mise en
garde à vue une garde à vue prolongée
jusqu'à demain pour les motifs suivants
violation de domicile dégradations
légères vol d'énergie rebellion envers
agents la propriétaire de la maison a
quant à elle déposé plainte